hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen adventure map und zwar der
adventure the drop hat zwei zusammen mit
max kraft der gruppe eins habe ich vor
ca weil sie nicht einem paar halbe
gemacht nicht mit ihm sondern mit der
gaming pc fünf damals auf jeden fall
sehr witzig er sah genauso aus wie
gropper 2 2-ausgleich hat nur mehr
levels und wir wollen das jetzt mal
durchmachen die ganze zeit ohne zu
schieben und es ist möglich wir haben
schon ein wenig trainiert weil so ein
anderer hat uns ein server gemacht
allerdings nicht so geil war
und da konnte man schon ein bisschen
trainieren und max stadler forderte die
max noch nicht hin ich bin max also dass
mein rat nahm werth ist gedacht mein
betrieb kanal heißt nicht max sondern
kran crafter bietet dort per flash max
youtube.com / krankhafter ich mache auch
minecraft videos wertes gedacht ich bin
gerade minecraft und bis jetzt main
kanal ist noch relativ jung glaube 45
tage alt es entstanden in einem
livestream mit dem werten herrn crafter
wir kennen uns aus dem reallife und ja
weil ich auch ab und zu bei minecraft
gezockt habe haben wir dann halt eben
urlaub wo wir uns kennengelernt haben
vor ein paar jahren haben wir dann halt
auch so ein bisschen minecraft gezockt
und dann sind wir nach hause gefahren
vom urlaub das dürfte damit bekommt man
bei luca dass er weg war sie mir nach
hause gefahren und haben dann live
stream zusammen gemacht und in dem live
stream der band lange campus männer in
einem livestream ist halt mein kanal
entstanden das war relativ lustig und
seitdem gibt es diesen kanal hier
krankhafter und ja ich mag wie gesagt
minecraft wie du sie können bei mir
vorbeischauen wenn ihr wollt und hätten
das
immer abwechselnd auf beiden kanälen
hofladen also gepaart ist gerade bei mir
der zweite part wird dann bei max offen
kann ich mit tod alter wieder stärker
geil bist du max liebe dich richtig
neiße kommt bei seite mit dem wir fangen
jetzt an hier
er wird während ihr mann schwert und
rüstung ausgegeben
schnell steht der fonds vor der
[ __ ] ist es der note sind alle
wirklich nix jungen heran welche auf
weite kannst du / klier inventory machen
dass die leute sehen dass ich nicht mehr
habe ich glaub an dich noch okay ich
probiere es aus klosters 68 gegen barca
sechs entfernt war ich meist ein halbes
deck steak hin sagt stimmt neuer man
kann ja hunger verlieren auf der karte
weil wir so oft sterben werden wenn ich
schnell die die regeln durchgehend also
zweite part wird morgen bei ihm sein
dritter partner kennt das wahrscheinlich
von apple blogs das machen möchte hier
noch importen video setting the distance
war habe ich habe ich cloud oft habe ich
das habe ich der ich habe es schon ob
das video auf settings wolken
ich hab rechts rechts ja du hast kein ob
tief eindringen ja dann wird das bei dir
auch viel besser laufen partikel
partikel ist habe ich auch nicht
gefunden also keine ahnung
als ob man es mir für lightning
ausmachen muss also dass es so schön
manche beleuchtung aus text cab active
default obmann okay kann bekanntlich
bleibt einfach jeweils relativ egal ich
mache das nächste steht graphics fest
für phorms power saver view robinov und
hier unten was steht da luca alter
achtet das ist reviews lag man dass man
das nicht hat
aufstehen und kontraste und kran crafter
gefängnis und jetzt das ist auch eine
sache um den lack zu reduzieren
red devils in scores aller cookie so war
ich jetzt schon zwei fans ab so 20 geil
wieder hier
aber ich hatte 15 zwei fehlversuche wenn
ihr seht rechts am rand hier einen
counter also wenn ihr gerade in der fei
scam seid dann seht ihr den das war
michael lucke das war bei maximal
gekeltert richtig mag es gut beobachtet
und wir fangen jetzt an drei zwei eins
los
wir sind jetzt hier und das ist so die
lobby weil hier sind sie die ganzen die
ganzen schilder sag ich mal wegen jetzt
erstmals level 1
und wer es zuerst schafft der
und muss selbst auch ich backe im boden
nicht im boden ich zurückschaue nicht
schon mal und los jetzt das gibt auch
okay und wir müssen jetzt versuchen der
einzelfall goal korrekt als zitate
gefallen jetzt mag ich auch nicht mehr
an boden
man muss dann immerhin wie möglichst in
mitte weil man relativ in der mitte
runterfällt so sterbe dann sehe ich so
dicht neben mir aufkommen die platschen
boden autobauer kommt abstand auf knapp
eltern genau nebeneinander aufgereiht
heißt also leute ist mit 100 venturelab
sein wo wir teilen das war eigentlich
nicht von uns kennt der scheiße alter
[ __ ] war also das wird eine fame exodus
ich benutze auch hier auf der adventures
benutze ich auch modus und alle hacks
eigentlich die man sich vorstellen kann
ich bin dafür bekannt dass ich gerne
hätte ich glaube das war immer noch ein
scherz von denen das war locker
ich glaube ehrlich mit einer rein
schreibt das die models in minecraft
modus ist ist ein hack ausschließlich
für minecraft lücker
es gibt glaube ich nur das noch in linx
klappt auch nicht trifft er war zu viel
ab alte weil ja das ist gut wenn ich da
am anfang bin und danach strikt ring ist
einfach mal gar nichts wenn man durch
die ersten beiden durch ist es nicht was
auf dem feld steht das letzte was mir
das bringt dir da bist du ja geil und
ich kann da gar nicht reinkommen
vielleicht so weit außen warten lukas
zum einlochen gekommen bist mal wieder
nicht zum einlochen gekommen
bei mir geht bei mir ging's los so
leicht gefallen weil er uns nicht lust
mir los los los alter bub durchgefallen
scheiße ich versteh ich verstehe diese
stammten dran hier die als ein
langweiliges keine ahnung durch beim
zweiten hektisch doch sogar schon mal
geschafft
ja ich habe zweimal geschafft weil ich
einmal die aber ich habe wir haben
trainiert
ein bisschen weil der server nicht
funktioniert hat so richtig ja genau wie
soll ich das denn schaffen möglichst
auch mal ein bisschen größer machen wir
bieten ja nicht
das war so knapp ich bin schon zweimal
durch weil einmal bin ich durch dann hab
ich mir logischerweise diamanten und
mitgenommen zeigen weil der hecking
diamanten hat es geschafft und dann da
hab ich mir dann aufgefallen als den
diamanten hat die sache jetzt wieder
dahin bringen
da muss ich noch mal richtig scheiße wir
werden noch hier werden auf tischplatten
zerbrechen
beim spielen junge dass das schlimmste
ist wenn du hast schaffst du ganz am
rand auf kommst und dann durch das loch
durch fällt sie hat eine leiche im
keller so hart wie viele gibt insgesamt
acht gibt es insgesamt wollen wir sagen
beifahrer bei 30 fails das nicht zu
lange zu langweilig für die zuschauer
bei 30 40
40 vergrößern wir das loch 40 ist mein
bizeps ungefähr
und beim zweiten wachst du einfach auf
ganzer linie weggeschlagen
ich schlage jetzt auch weg
es wird mit viel aggressionspotenzial
sein
13 junge wertlos in der anderen
warum sagst es mir auch noch erschwert
einen diamanten diamanten werden
diamanten man vorhin mal geschafft nie
das erste loch gestopft und schaffte das
grab da also ihr müsst wissen ich bin
eigentlich immer besser als luca ihr
könnt ihr dann genau beobachten wie es
aussieht wenn ihr mini-tief folge als
nächstes bei mir du bist bei mir des
todes in der wand
okay leute erst mal runterfallen inso
spinnennetze rein damit gebremst ist
durch hässliche alter hast du keine
geschwindigkeit
ich bin dadurch geschlittert
ich habe geschwindigkeit also auf 26 in
der mitte kommen wir da das habe ich
schon gemacht aber das andere noch nicht
und du musst jetzt den weg hierunter
finden alte zum beispiel erst mal hier
drauf alter halbes herz ja wie du
einfach den weg schon kennst du scheiße
das ist überall der gleiche weg du musst
also essen auf die seite ja das ist
überall der gleiche weg auf die an ihrer
seite
du musst nur unter schülern jetzt habe
ich keinen speed mein alter ich hab's
trotzdem geschafft anderthalb herzen
wenn kräfte wie schaffe ich das denn
jetzt ohne dass ich ja ich muss auf
jeden fall erstmal wie hast du das
überhaupt am anfang geschafft alte haye
ich stehe ja immer wenn ich unter fall
ja du musst dich in die mitte stellen
nachdem auf den schalter gedrückt hat
ihnen diese spinnen letzte rein ja neben
fast für uns drin
ich würde er tut ihr gut dann stehe ich
jetzt hier auf dem dinge ich muss ach so
wahrscheinlich okay wir kombinieren und
alte halbes jetzt das haben wir auch so
ich hab zwar volles lebt [ __ ] weil sie
generiert aber recht schnell
warum ist das so man verliert aber nicht
sein inventar nähe wenn er sterben das
auch relativ gut heißt es war eine weise
entscheidung dass wir 16 gegeben haben
ich war so nah vor boden jung ich habe
ich habe zwei diamanten als ob ich habe
mir zwei diamanten ja als ob du das
geschafft du bist wie denn komme hierher
ich habe einfach gefunden keine ahnung
ich bin ja immer komm zu mir komm zu mir
ich tippe ich mal ja nein du gehst mich
nicht ist es hätten ja es ist wo willst
du denn ich habe schon zwei diamanten
junge hat sagt mir du bist bist du noch
hälfte auf der map kommen ja klar du
auch er sagt mir wenn ich da so am rand
stehen
ich sehe da nahm ihn irgendwo ja ich bin
ich weit unten
also musste erst mal auf so der ob
dieses treppen ähnliche teile drauf
springen und runter und dann holst akku
jetzt nicht den namen jetzt guckt ja
jung ich war schon viel weiter und
leiter wir pech gehabt denn jemand man
lieber alter ich war übels weit unten
wie wie kann er hier in diamant seien
drin
vielleicht gibt es ja noch ein aber du
bist grad relativ leise max ich bin
leise jetzt leise dass man eher als
nächstes zu gehen so ein bisschen so
besser immer noch leise ich verstehe das
nicht ich meine bei mir komme ich hier
die ganze zeit so freudig runter als
wäre nichts passiert
wolfert halbes jahr egal aber ich
verstehe das nicht wieso findest du denn
so einfach finden die hatten ja ich bin
unten des todes und dann guck mal coca
cola es kann auch nicht sein hätte er
das tier das er feierlich da ist an der
seite sowie über wasser da kannst du von
ganz oben in so ein kleines becken
springen wenn du bist du glück hast du
musst erst mal ein bisschen runter damit
nicht so viel falsch haben
ich bin ganz runter ganz unter
gesprungen jetzt kann ich wahr sein
alter ich glaub ihr runter und runter
und rakka und tue und nach und der
spring in so einen scheiß becken
reinalter der mann muss man muss man
muss die augen haben wir die augen muss
man haben
es kann nicht wahr sein und ich lerne
direkt neben dem becken aus zehn blöcken
fick dich lochen diamant jemand alter
ich glatt dich zusammen wenn ich dich
sehe man es kann auch sein nicht aber
ich freu mich einfach so unter eher geil
was ich versuche jetzt auch mal direkt
in das wasserbecken leute und ich bin
natürlich verteilen wo kein wasser
bitten ist natürlich und darf keine
blöcke abmontierten holzschwerter zu
kräften
das bringt den schmetterball verängstigt
töten will ja auch ob jetzt ein
wasserbett ist hast du die uhr im blick
da ist ja ja ja hab ich ja zwei level
sind eigentlich ganz gut ich sagen in
der zeit die wir gemacht haben sind zwei
diamanten gut in der zeitlupe wie viel
hast du eigentlich wie viel hast du halt
auch dass das wasser getroffen hatte war
steht da jetzt besteht ein pfeil
weil man hier steht die bluttaten
steckte die fördern einen rück- den
schwarzen drückt den schwarzen und
springen mal treffe ich das wasserbecken
ich hab kein schaden bekommen und direkt
neben ihr steht tod direkt am anfang
sehr freuen ich würde sagen es war ein
perfektes ende nächster path morgen auf
dem kanal von max kran kraft da steht
oben in der beschreibung genau und man
geht da das ferien bzw
videos und kommentare schreiben was ihr
von dieser map haltet die besser findet
als die glocke 1 also ich muss auf jeden
fall sagen ja weil es ist auch schon
besser organisiert ich muss auch sagen
ja weil es diese geile sprung
verstärkung gerade eben gab
das ist der hauptgrund vor allem die
jobs einfach so schön gespielt hast dich
ja habe ich
und wie das mit den blossen euro
funktioniert weiß nicht dass erklären
uns auch egal es und bis morgen bei max